their news the Justice Department is
considering its next move this morning
after a federal judge ordered it to turn
over secret grand jury testimony from
Robert mullahs Muller's Russia
investigation to the house this coming
week the ruling is being seen as a
victory for Democrats and potential new
fuel for the impeachment inquiry into
the president Trump Ben Tracy is at the
White House with the latest Ben good
morning good morning this is a big deal
for Democrats because in this ruling the
judge says that their impeachment
inquiry is lawful and that severely
undercuts the arguments of the White
House and the president who have been
calling this illegitimate a sham at a
witch-hunt being destroyed and
humiliated at a historically black
college in South Carolina Friday
President Trump compared the way
minorities experienced the criminal
justice system with his own impeachment
inquiry and I have my own experience you
know that you see what's going on with
the witch-hunt it's a terrible thing
that's going on in our country no crimes
there it's an investigation in search of
a crime that investigation is moving
quickly Democrats on Friday issued three
more subpoenas for administration
officials to testify before Congress
including the acting director of the
White House Budget Office and CBS News
has learned that attorneys for former
national security adviser John Bolton
are consulting with lawmakers about
cooperating
while the president continues to insist
he did not ask Ukraine to investigate
Joe Biden and his family in exchange for
military aid the White House is
scrambling to form a communications team
dedicated to dealing with the
impeachment inquiry although mr. Trump
says there is only one defender in chief
here's the thing I don't have teams
everyone's talking about him I'm the
team
I did nothing wrong in some possible
good news for the president the Justice
Department has launched a criminal
investigation into how its own probe of
Russian election interference began in
2016 the president has long wanted an
investigation of the investigators I
will tell you this I think you're gonna
see a lot of really bad things
now Republicans on Capitol Hill and
senior administration officials here at
the White House tell CBS News that the
president's team is losing the messaging
battle on impeachment the hope is that
by having some sort of Rapid Response
Team they can try to fix that Jeff thank
you very much